hi everyone welcome to homeroom with sal
we have a very exciting show and very
exciting guest today eric schmidt but
before we jump into that conversation i
will give my standard announcements
first a reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization and we can
only exist through donations from folks
like yourself so if you're in a position
to do so
please think about going to khan
academy.org slash donate
i also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations that stepped up
over the last few months some many of
them have been supporting us over the
years but especially when they saw that
we were running at a deficit pre-covet
and our cost went up because of kovid
we've had 250 percent of typical traffic
a special thanks to bank of america
google.org att fastly and novartis for
helping us fill that gap but we still
need more help especially for 2021 so
please think about making a gift i also
want to make a reminder announcement
that there's a version of this live
stream that you can get wherever you get
your podcast homeroom with sal the
podcast
so with that i am super uh excited to
introduce our guest eric schmidt uh eric
uh there's a lot of things folks know
about you you are former ceo of google
you were the executive chairman of
google you're an advisor to google
you're actually a former board member of
khan academy you've been a supporter of
khan academy uh over the years uh thank
you for joining us
well thank you saul and you know when we
we first met and you had this little
operation in mountain view
i knew the impact that you would have
would be fantastic but the combination
of a new set of tools and frankly the
pandemic has accelerated you to this
sort of new level that's really
remarkable so congratulations to you and
the team i'm sure it's been intense
it has i you know you know obviously
it's been an unfortunate situation for
the world but it it you know it's been
nice that we had something to do very
something very critical to do so so
there's
interesting by the way
i learned one thing
i learned many things from you when i
was on your board
but i don't know if you remember when
you first had this idea
of looking at math and trying to figure
out which the minimum number of math
questions to get the maximum amount of
knowledge transferred and i thought that
was a great public service to all
students by the khan academy and so the
fact that you could back solve to what
math exercises you have to do would have
saved me an enormous amount of time when
i was learning math
well you seem like you've done just fine
and i'm flattered because uh back in the
day i thought all of the learning was
was coming towards me so i'm glad a
little bit went upstream
upstream to you
so so there's a ton to talk about i
encourage everyone watching on youtube
and facebook put questions in the
message boards we have team members who
are going to surface them to eric and
myself literally about every anything
and everything but one of the things
that where i want to start is on a a
pretty powerful project that you're
working on and actually i'm
collaborating with you on
call the rise program or the rye
scholars program tell us
what this is and why you decided to to
get involved in this
well it's interesting that i tried to
figure out when i left google what i
what was really important and it turns
out the most important thing was talent
and i was talking to my various friends
and i said well how did you know that
you were unique in this area that's code
for are you a nerd uh in this way and
they said that roughly what happened was
when they were a teenager which is an
awkward time for everybody there was
some kind of teacher or mentor or
experience that got them to understand
that they had a special gift
so then talking to everybody we had this
idea of building an app
which we ultimately asked you to build
so thank you for that they would try to
identify
students in that sort of 15 17 age group
with exceptional talent and i don't just
mean math though and i mean any kind of
talent but they're really off the charts
amazing
and the idea was
that if we that if we did this
what we would do is we would um
figure out a way to get a list of such
people and then working with the rhodes
trust we would figure out a way
to
identify starting with a hundred of them
so you're part of this grand experiment
no i and i i want to emphasize you know
how excited i am about this project i
mean you're seeing here on the screen
some of these students who are able to
submit submissions and one of the really
powerful things i mean i think what you
touch on is you know there's these super
young people around the world
and you know you myself we were all
probably lucky early in our life to have
certain people really believe us and
certain people support us and if we can
create a framework so that they can feel
supported you know selfishly speaking
these are the young people who are going
to cure the diseases we're going to
solve the major social problems we're
going to be the entrepreneurs the
artists uh that that really move society
forward you know on your on your title
go ahead eric well what happened was so
we wandered around we talked to you and
your team we talked to some other teams
and there are groups that do a pretty
good job of surfacing
talent but they are not uni they're not
uniform across the world so
became clear
that there was talent that was not being
found and so the insight was it's pretty
reasonable that that pretty much any
teenager has access to either their own
mobile phone or someone near them has
them pretty much everywhere so we had
the idea which again i think was really
your idea of let's have them start by
submitting videos
right because a video is hard for them
to fake
right and it's a good project to get
them
who are they what do they care about
what is special about them so that's the
grand experiment
yeah i remember when we first started
talking over a year ago and your team
reached out and they they said hey you
know we're interested in finding these
really high potential kids around the
world maybe a lot of them are using khan
academy and i said yes a lot of them
very well could be using khan academy
maybe a lot of them are watching this
right now but i said what would be
really cool is if we could capture your
traditional academic content mastery
whatever you want to call it things that
traditional test scores measure because
that's important and honestly khan
academy prepares a lot of that you have
things like sats which we partner with
but then there's other things that
traditionally aren't measured like your
sense of humor your creativity your your
entrepreneurship and we brainstormed
together and said let's create this app
and the app is called hello world uh
where we have essentially have
challenges actually you have a challenge
there on how someone can change the
world i put a challenge on there where
people need to figure out ways to make
me laugh and when they submit these
videos they also get to review other
people's videos and help them on their
journey uh to to grow themselves uh and
what we're hoping is that not just for
the rise program but this could be a new
way of folks being able to show who they
are
showcase who they are and and get access
to opportunities you know one thing that
i'm sure a lot of folks are thinking
about is well what does this mean let's
say let's say i run i won i become a
rise scholar i'm one of that hundred
this year
what's going to happen to my life
well hopefully um
with the first place at some point the
pandemic will be over
and at that point that cohort will will
have some kind of residential program
you know three or four weeks together
which we think will be transformative
what we know is that each person has a
specialized set of problems and
opportunities so we'll start with trying
to make sure that they're operating at
their full potential with career and
career and
college counseling and so forth if they
need a way to get into a university in
the us we'll find a way these are people
who will get into wherever they apply
but we want to encourage them to apply
wherever
as part of this we've made a commitment
that it's a lifelong program so over
time we'll provide mentoring and help
and we'll also take the older
recipients and use them to
mentor the younger ones
because of the way our model works we
are also going to start tracking
whether the signals that your app
produces ultimately are predictive of
future behavior so the key thing is we
have an idea of what shows excellence
and there's some anecdotal
data but over say a decade we'll be able
to say
these cohorts and these characteristics
are the most likely to predict future
success with the help we're providing so
that's really interesting to me
and i really want to emphasize this i've
been telling you know every young person
that i meet who i think could you know
have a chance at this i was like you
have to look seriously at this program i
think you you you said in a very light
way but you know students who win this
they're going to get access to a lot of
mentors a lot of support once again not
just now and through college but for the
rest of their lives if they have ideas
on how to help humanity they want to
start a business they want to start a
not-for-profit essentially you're
creating an ecosystem
for to support them
uh we are and let's discuss what will
the world look like in 25 or 50 years
they're going to be more people
it's also going to be more complicated
humans are really good at building
complex governance systems political
systems social systems
so this next generation of neat leaders
are needed now and they have to be up to
the task of an even more complicated and
interconnected world
and i'm excited about that i think that
my general view is the sooner we can
turn
the current regime over to a younger
generation who can er you know fix the
mistakes we've made and make some new
ones i think the better
and you know and i forgot it's my bad
you know you're the co-founder of
schmidt futures and schmidt futures is
kind of the creator of this rise program
explain what schmidt futures hopes to do
generally speaking and how rise fits in
that
well it's become the vehicle to express
the things that i care about which
started off with talent we're also
spending a lot of time funding science
there's a new generation of scientists
there always is and they are
accelerating discoveries in key aspects
of science uh medicine
math those sorts of things and i'm
funding at a very large level so far
i'm getting very interested in the
notion of creating institutes around new
problems so for example we have created
a virtual institute that's a code for a
funding system to look at the really
hard science problems in climate change
i'm not talking about dealing with it
i'm talking about why
we still don't understand for example
the relationship of sea ice and the sea
around it and exactly why it melts the
way it does these sorts of things
there's plenty of science to be done and
i'm trying to fund it and especially
since the government is now funding
r d at the lowest percentage since
sputnik 1.7 so literally
what is it 70 years later it's the same
percentage of gdp for science that's
insane
right nevertheless that's where we are
so this is an opportunity for private
philanthropy i'm also extremely
interested in learning and frankly this
came out of i don't know if you remember
but you had an event at your house
um
before back when we could have events in
houses
where we talked a lot about
education you were with bill gates who's
a big funder of khan academy as well
and one of the ideas there was to try to
build the database of of information
about how people learn
so that's called learning engineering
and it turns out we have lots of
opinions about how people learn but we
don't actually have any provable data we
don't have any ai science around this so
i'm trying to fund that as well
it's a pretty bold goal i mean you know
if i read between the lines it's really
you're stepping up and you are stepping
up in massive ways
to kind of help fill this gap uh that
that normally is done by nations and and
governments
you know what what we're obviously a
very unique time with the political
environment with covid with what's going
on on you know work and and remote work
and all of that
what and given your your orgs schmidt
futures what is your sense of the future
if we're looking back five years from
now 10 years from now what do you think
is going to change for the better and
what do you think is going to change for
the worse
well i i don't mean to say the obvious
but when a historian looks when
historians look at the west's
performance with respect to the pandemic
they're going to give us an f
um democracy as it's currently
formulated is not serving the health and
the health and safety of the citizens of
europe and of south america and of the
united states there are a few
democracies in asia primarily that have
managed to get through this there's a
couple in europe but otherwise it's been
a disaster
the reason i'm hammering on this
is that the compound negative impact of
the pandemic especially on minorities
and the underserved is going to be hard
for us to catch up i thought things were
going pretty good before the pandemic
things were getting better but if you
look at ratios of inequality the issues
of education and so forth one of the
reasons that khan academy is so
important is there's evidence that
especially
students of color people who without
without proper means are literally going
to miss out on a whole year of education
because the schools are closed or
partially open
so we've got to collectively solve this
problem the future of our nation is at
stake having said that as sort of the
number one concern there's all sorts of
reasons to think that the the model of
uh entrepreneurial discovery the kind of
creativity that we're doing is going to
accelerate uh for all sorts of reasons
so if we can just get through this
pandemic with minimal loss of life and
get people back to school and to work
which somehow the at least the trump
administration seems to have forgotten
to focus on at the moment
and we're waiting now on the biden
transition which is two months away
which is insane during the middle of a
pandemic
but nevertheless i think that's where we
are
there's every reason to think that we
can make great progress in biology and
chemistry
in mental health
in uh use of
i don't know telehealth i mean there's
an example after example i'm the
chairman of the reimagine commission for
new york state and we've looked a lot at
what the future looks like
and once you have relatively broadly
available broadband
it's possible to have a somewhat more
effective and somewhat more efficient
learning experience on an entertaining
experience etc i'm not one of these
people who thinks we go back i think we
go forward and the new world is much
more hybrid
as an aside one of the things that the
pandemic has proven
is that people can be productive working
from home if they choose to
so it looks to me
like we've got some new fundamental
learnings in our society which are
probably positive after this terrible
experience
and there's a lot in that i mean on just
the the second to last thing you
mentioned then i want to get to the last
thing you mentioned the notion of uh
essentially access to broadband and the
digital divide what's yours and you know
you've had
ties to government and probably talking
to them advising them obviously your
role at google
what what do you think are the chances
that we can finally close the digital
divide at home i mean my back of the
envelope it would be one to two percent
of one of these rounds of stimulus would
essentially do the job
what do you think our odds are
that's why that's why the current
situation is insane the government is
being forced because of economic
activity come up with a number of
trillion dollar bailouts
all we need is
50 billion
100 billion to both wire up the rest of
the country and
fund all the rapid testing fund all the
sentinel systems fund all the knowledge
systems to keep us safe and yet every
time this comes up it doesn't get funded
there's something wrong here there's
some some cognitive problem but in any
case in our new york work we discovered
that there are hundreds of thousands of
households in new york state that have
do not have effective access to
broadband
now you might say there's plenty of
rural people and the rural people suffer
because their primary access is cellular
so you know it's literally on a cell
phone but there are many many
underserved communities within the
cities of our nation and it's just
it's just stupid it's basically because
the prices are too high there's no
subsidy or there are subsidies but the
people are not aware of it
um or the build out has not completed
and so forth and we've got to address
that so as part of our commission we're
making a set of recommendations which
essentially say
in order to operate going forward you
have to embrace universal broadband and
you have to measure it i'll give you a
simple example
under the fcc rules you can count
connectivity based on a single household
within a
zip code in other words it the coverage
looks a lot better than it really is
and so we propose for example
crowdsourcing the actual coverage map so
we can figure out who actually has
broadband and you'll be surprised where
the holes are
here i'm in new york city
new york city and you spend a lot of
time in new york
new york has plenty of holes it's easy
to cover if you want to
that's fascinating and what's your sense
you know assuming we are able to cover
it and i i the silver lining i've never
seen more energy than we're seeing right
now at hopefully closing digital divide
you know that kind of your last point
that you had made around the future of
work and that people realize that they
can be reasonably productive remote you
know given your vantage point as
uh you know former ceo of you know the
techies of tech companies uh that has a
lot of infrastructure for that allows
people to work remotely
what do you think is going to happen to
work and
business travel and all of that
well there's a couple of interesting
statistics one is that only about 30
percent of the workforce can effectively
work from home
think about the number of people who are
in security guards they open doors
they're have to be in some kind of
manufacturing facility to oversee
something they're teachers who have to
be in a classroom etc there's so many
jobs
which are not able to work from home at
the moment and for those who wish to
work from home some of them don't have
environments as we discussed where they
have appropriate broadband or maybe they
don't even have a working environment
where they can do their work because
they live in a relatively cramped place
which wasn't a problem now it is because
they have no space to to focus on what
you and i are talking about so i think
these things will adjust
and i think the most important thing is
that we're not going to go back to the
structured nine to five in the office
it's going to be more flexible they're
going to be more hybrid models
also and i don't mean to be a downer on
this but the pandemic will go on for a
long time
even if you make the most uh most
positive assumptions about vaccine
effectiveness and so forth the rate at
which the vaccine works the number of
people who get it
the effectiveness of the vaccine in
terms of length of time means that we're
going to be operating in this strange
hybrid mass model for probably more than
a year from now maybe longer
so we need to have a plan to get our
to get our businesses back to work to
get our students educated to have our
mental health address and frankly to
have some fun and enjoy our lives during
this period
no it's fascinating and there's so much
that that's in flux so we're getting a
ton of questions on facebook and youtube
so the first question from facebook
mandy
roby do students apply them they're
asking is this i guess about the rise
program do students apply themselves or
do they have to be nominated i could
take that but if you want to and and the
answer is both
uh you can nominate yourself and you can
be nominated by somebody
and there is an app
entitled hello world-rise
which is available on google play and on
the apple app store
and i encourage people to download it
and i wonder who wrote that app saul
yeah just for everyone you know as we
mentioned earlier this app is a project
it's a it's actually a cousin project of
khan academy it's another not-for-profit
called hello world and
i'm the chairperson of it but i've been
working very closely with that team to
think about you know in a world where
khan academy can have people learn at
their own pace kind of core academic
things have supports ideally do it in a
classroom setting but also be able to do
it on their own how does someone prove
who they are to the world and hello
world uh is that app and i encourage
anyone listening to apply to that you
know sometimes folks might say oh wow
there's going to be 100 kids in the
world maybe i'm not one of those hundred
kids but i encourage you this app is
going to look at dimensions of your
personality that you might not have
appreciated yet uh and that we might
appreciate if you're really funny if you
creative if you it's not just your
traditional assessments now we are also
going to be looking at people who are
off the charts in you know in
traditional measures as well but i
encourage everyone to apply and even if
this year you're not able to get the
rise program just going through the
process of of going to the app and going
to these challenges we're hoping over
time to connect students all of y'all
with other opportunities as well
opportunities other scholarships
higher education opportunities and and
jobs so encourage everyone to download
the hello world app and apply
and saul you and i have talked about
this before but i'd really like you to
take this app that you guys have built
and use it for more general assessment
self-assessment by students
as we learn what's great about people
maybe this app can help you provide a
better experience in your learning
programs and also better referrals so i
think the platform you built is well
broader than what ryze is offering and i
think you can pull that off
that that's what we're hoping and you
know that's what we're very excited
about working with ryze is kind of the
first
uh end goal for for the app because as
we said and i think you know
you're you're being very humble with
what this program is i mean you know i'm
telling every young person if my if my
older son was a little bit older i'd be
like you're applying for that tonight
we've been waiting for your kids to grow
up for a while you know we talk about
your kids all day
no no nepotism it would be on their own
merits but this is a great program for
anyone who honestly anyone who just goes
through the process of applying i think
it's going to be a really powerful thing
you're going to have artifacts that
you're going to be able to show
folks to impress them and get
opportunity and then for the folks who
become finalists and the folks who get
become part of the scholars program i
this is generally going to be
life-changing and you get to be part of
that that first class of people that
that are going to be heavily heavily
invested in um so there's other
questions coming in
over here oh whoops i dropped my my
headphones so one question here and we
touched on a little bit but maybe we'll
double down this from youtube
smartbear5 asks
how will schmidt futures change the
future you mentioned you know some
things in kind of scientific discovery
filling the gap of government you know
in your in your dream but still you know
reasonably pragmatic and you know what
how do you hope that the future will be
different because of schmidt futures
let's say in 20 years
well what i hope is true is that we have
an unusually good
model for talent
in other words that we can just somehow
feel the talent better than others and
so we collect these teams together so
what i'm particularly excited about
which i'm working on now is try to
identify the really hard problems in
society i'll give you one inequality the
inequality is getting worse how is this
okay it's clearly not
i'm very interested in
moving the ai platforms beyond their
current technology base to more
aggressive uses of ai in terms of
knowledge learning i'm very interested
in using ai to approximate functions
that have never been computable before
this occurs in chemistry and physics and
biology
i'm very very interested in the progress
that people can make in biological
systems now
it used to be that you had to sort of
manually adjust where you thought the
targets of drugs were and how the the
various components of biology work and
now you can use synthetic synthesis
programs that will actually do this
there's evidence of people who can use
synthetic biology at scale now to build
parts of life that would be helpful for
human existence and i can just go on and
on and on
i could i could talk to you for hours
about pretty much every clause of what
you just said what you just talked about
i mean you know
just just to you know underline some of
what you said i mean it sounds like this
work just even one dimension that last
dimension you referred to this could we
could accelerate the number of drugs we
discover and make them more effective by
an order of magnitude or two i mean that
just that would be a massive
so so it's interesting that there's a
drug that was just developed called
halacine
it was developed by a group at mit
and the group had a synthetic biologist
who was brilliant and a computer
scientist who was brilliant and a number
of other chemists who were brilliant and
they worked together as a team for a
couple of years to actually build a drug
that appears to be a new class of
antibiotics that was discovered by
computer if that is a replicable model
right so here's a proof point then it
looks like a whole bunch of problems
that have been deviled humanity for a
very long time will be close
to falling we'll see of course drugs
take a long time to develop and they
have to be safe and all of that
that's mind-blowing and just to explain
everyone watching because you know
there's a lot of young people here
trying to figure out what do i do with
my life what is a synthetic biologist
explain what that is how's that
different
synthetic biology is the creation of
what you think of as life that is carbon
carbon consuming
um cells if you will
um
using essentially a computer
and there are techniques where the cells
are essentially combined and you get
something which is a life form now by
the way we're not creating humans with
this we're dealing with you know tiny
little tiny little things but those tiny
little things can be for example
put as part of a drug
to help some biological process they can
also be used to detect things so the for
various biology is very powerful and
we're just learning how powerful it is
and so for things like i don't know like
the classic example in synthetic biology
is fuels that do not have carbon in them
um in other words synthetic fuels and
that's another example today synthetic
biology is primarily focused on new drug
categories because frankly that's where
all the money is
now that's that's i mean it's mind
blowing even when you talked about that
not only are you kind of synthesizing
new organisms or new molecules but the
how to synthesize is being informed by
artificial intelligence i'm assuming
it's being trained on data of what other
types of molecules have been able to do
and as far as being antibiotics or
something like that and that's being
able to create new molecules
it's interesting that it's pretty clear
that 30 years ago if someone asked you
what field you should get into it the
correct answer was computer science
computer science has sort of taken over
the world in terms of it's now the
number one major in most universities
it's accepted as a mainstream activity
whereas 30 years ago it was sort of
crazy people like me it was seen as sort
of saw on the side now it's mainstream
what's the next one it's clearly biology
because biology is so deep so powerful
and so poorly understood at the biola at
the molecular level at the processes
level
um
once you so here's an example we can't
build a fully functioning model of a
digital cell yet
think about it we should be able to do
that
there are teams that are now trying to
build small models of huma not human but
mouse brains and things like that again
we're off by an order of magnitude of
the ability to do it the biological
world is so much more complicated than i
thought and is likely to be chippable a
wayable whatever the word is
because of the advances of the
technologies that i'm describing so to
me if i were to give advice to a young
person if you can do biology and biology
is fascinating it has a heavy math
component again touch up on your math
but the fact of the matter is that's
where the money is going to be in the
same sense that it used to be computer
science
yeah and it sounds like i mean it's
really the convergence of these two
because it's really the computing that
is allowing us because biological
processes have been so unfathomably
complicated and you know you mentioned
the cell and you know there's a video on
khan academy i still remember doing this
where i had like this this you know we
have this image of the cell that a lot
of books have this very simple thing
with the nucleus but the reality of a
cell it's like a whole universe in there
and the complexity of how it works it's
mind-boggling but the fact that we can
start to understand it
i'm funding a project
a large project which has not yet been
announced
to try to understand how the cells
communicate with each other think of it
as the biology of life
we don't even understand the signaling
between the various components of the
cell we sort of we can see the cell we
can name the parts the micro microscopes
are really good but we don't understand
how how how the transformations occur
and the theory is that there's probably
a unifying language
it's one that we haven't discovered yet
which is which was
built by god and by nature which is at
the basis of all of that now that's cool
no it is it is mind-blowing i can't tell
you how many times that even when i was
trying to cover the biology for khan
academy uh which is you know apparently
you know entry-level college-level
biology or high school level biology
that sometimes i was like okay the
textbook says a leads to b but why does
that really really happen then i'd call
some friend who's you know a professor
at johns hopkins or duke or mit or
stanford and they say actually sal you
just stumbled on a cutting edge you know
we don't know the answer to that and
it's exactly what you described we don't
there's so much that we don't you know
we're we're a big bag of trillions of
cells and we really just don't
understand it at all
but but i think for your for the
students that you work with you know
your customer base if you will
the most important thing to understand
is that there's so much going on that's
sexy and interesting in these fields
that if you get it all interested in
just run at them and khan academy has
all the initial information that you
need and if it wets your appetite then
online you and so to you know in my case
i was interested in computers when i was
a sort of 15 year old
i would have had the internet existing
which it didn't i would have been deeply
into it as a 16 year old because i was
so interested i would have spent all
night just playing with it playing games
learning how it worked experimenting
with it that possibility is now in front
of you in all of these fields
no it's really mind-blowing and i see
how it all fits together because schmidt
futures is both working on the
technology and the processes and the
science of the future and also the
pipeline of everyone not just in science
but the people who are going to be able
to make the change because it's not just
going to be science that has to be
forwarded and technology is going to be
policy it's going to be the arts
everything is going to evolve and that's
what y'all are what we're trying to find
with the with the with the rise fellows
but one of the things about you saw is
that in order to do what you do you have
to be insanely curious
so a good rule of life for again our
our constituencies our customers our
students what have you
is just keep asking questions and
challenge assumptions i hate it
when people say well the following is
true and i check it and it's not and i
say look right here's the evidence and
then they're so stuck on their idea they
don't realize there's an alternative
it's called critical thinking so as you
explore these fields the critical
thinking that you will develop
will be so powerful
in terms of your life your ability to
you know and when the government does
something stupid or the media lies to
you or somebody misleads you or whatever
you'll be able to say you know what
i actually know the answer i have the
strength of my own convictions because
i've done the research i can do the
critical thinking and i know what is
true and i'm going to pursue this
because i'm passionate about it and
that's when greatness happens
no it's very powerful and just to close
out these conversations always go much
faster than i expected i just looked at
it like oh we're all out of time you
know and you already touched on this but
there's a lot of 15 to 17 year olds
listening uh or even younger a little
bit older there's a lot of their parents
a lot of teachers listening
what advice do you have for these young
people i mean you touched on a little
bit if you were if you know
the the younger version of yourself when
you're 15 or 16 but it's 20 20 you see
what would what would you tell them to
do
try to learn calculus
i know that's a boring answer but it's
actually true if you can master calculus
you don't have to even be good at it
if you at least understand calculus then
you'll have the critical thinking in the
analytical capabilities to do economics
the law
any of the sciences any of the math any
of the things that i care about so to me
if you can get yourself to the point
where you can do calculus and again khan
academy is fantastic on this stuff i
think it will have a huge impact
so you know it's the old thing of in the
graduate movie way back when he said the
answer is plastics so my answer is
calculus
no that's super fun i didn't expect you
to say that but i love your answer
because one i also love calculus and
khan academy is a great place to learn
that and you're absolutely right even if
you don't take a derivative or an
integral in your future life it shows
that you have the kind of the analytical
capability to think fairly deeply about
things and today there are supports to
do it you can learn your own type time
and based on khan academy practice
videos
we actually have another effort another
cousin effort called uh
schoolhouse.world where you actually get
free tutoring for calculus and then you
can prove what you know and then become
a tutor yourself and that can lead you
to opportunities and then obviously on
hello world you can apply whether it's
your calculus your science skills your
computing skills your create artistic
creativity uh to lead lead to
opportunity well you know i could talk
for hours about any one of the sentences
you mentioned today but thank you so
much
well let me thank you saul you've
changed the world you've changed
probably a million lives already and
you're on your way to 10 million
i admire what you've done having you as
a partner is one of the great things in
my life today and i want to do more with
you thank you so much for having me on
your show
no well uh eric it's the feeling is more
than mutual you've been a you know and i
you know you were very kind when you
said you learned something from me but
in the early days of khan academy i i
remember when um 60 minutes was doing a
piece on khan academy and then the
producer randomly said oh yeah we got
eric schmidt i was like eric schmidt
knows who i am
and then you you i mean i remember at
the end anyone could find it on on
youtube that ended that 60 minutes piece
you were very generous about you know
who i was like that helped me believe in
myself if eric schmidt believes that
about me maybe
maybe i should do something with my
so we're trying to recreate that feeling
style that i inadvertently created in
you for a million people
using your app on the rise program
that's what we want to do we want that
feeling that you felt that lifted you we
want everyone to have that feeling
imagine if we can pull that off together
no i love that i love that let's let's
do that and it's going to be selfishly
motivated because these are the young
people who are going to entertain us and
drive
discovery of medicines and keep us alive
longer and and make our lives better so
i'm excited to go on this journey with
you eric
okay thanks again sal
thank you
well thanks everyone for joining a super
exciting conversation on a lot of levels
i mean i literally could talk to eric
about every one of those things that
schmidt futures is working on because
there you could write like a science
fiction story about each of them
but i do want to encourage everyone
listening whether you are a teenager
whether you know a teenager whether
you're the parent of a teenager or
teachers of teenagers uh take a serious
look at this rise scholars program as i
talked about with eric this is not some
let's call it a small scholarship this
is something that is literally
transformational for a young person's
life just going through the process of
going to hello world and applying for it
you can see the url right there
risefortheworld.org
apply and this is the first year and i
think when you get in on the ground for
something that's even that much more
exciting so encourage everyone watching
to apply and get everyone else to apply
it literally is going to be a
life-changing opportunity for you
so with that i will uh see you actually
i'll see you in a little while uh
probably after thanksgiving break i'm
going on a little bit of a vacation so
i'll see y'all uh in i guess that's
gonna be december see y'all then
you